we're staggering by any measure here to
talk about those numbers and more CBS
News senior business analyst Jill
Schlesinger Jill good morning to you the
job loss numbers staggering as we
mentioned but we're still not seeing the
full extent of all this that's right
because remember the jobs report takes
place the the two surveys in the first
half of the month and we certainly know
that the second half of the month will
bring far more people onto the
unemployment rolls and by many measures
it looks like that the unemployment rate
under estimates the true depth of these
problems and here's why if you are not
actively seeking work you are not
considered part of the labor force well
a lot of people who were surveyed said
I'm not looking for work I'm not
supposed to be out looking for work that
actually kept the unemployment rate
artificially low when we look at the
broader unemployment rate which is more
far-reaching that number is close to 23%
and you know what Jeff that number is
agonizing to look at we have not seen
numbers like that since the Great
Depression
this is ten times the worst single month
right after World War two 25 times worth
worse a single month that we saw in the
Great Recession but it also said that in
April report that wages were actually up
how does that work so strange because
you would say how is that possible
unfortunately this is not good news it's
because the number of people who were
low wage earners were disproportionately
impacted they came out of the labor
force and then everybody else who's left
in it appears they got a wage increase
this is obviously really not the truth
the true picture of the labor market
right now also jill worth pointing out
that unemployment benefits and
guidelines vary widely from state to
state why is that and what effect does
that have
it's very strange in the United States
it's unlike many other developed nations
we have a blended approach a state and
federal system where essentially as long
as the states follow general guidelines
that the government puts out it
make decisions about eligibility for
unemployment length of unemployment and
so we have many areas where people are
going to see their unemployment benefits
basically run out just within a few
months other areas of the country they
could last for longer one good piece of
information of course is that those
enhanced unemployment benefits from the
federal government those last through
July that's that extra $600 a week so
we've talked about some of the
businesses that were affected right off
the bat here are the biggest probably
being the restaurant industry what are
the latest industries and jobs that have
been going away you know we've been
talking a lot about what happens to
retail we had two big retailers filed
for chapter 11 bankruptcy this week we
have the high-end right and in Neiman
Marcus and then we had j.crew to two
very significant retailers now it's
unclear how many of their stores will
reopen when they come out of bankruptcy
but there are going to be additional
layoffs we also saw Silicon Valley be
impacted for the first time pretty
significantly a quarter of Airbnb
workers let go
seventeen percent of lift workers
furloughed or laid off and then there's
over where there's fourteen percent of
its workforce cut so it's deep it's
troubling and we'll hopefully get better
in the next few months Jeff okay Jill
Schlesinger thank you very much Michele
over to you new